what exactly is a zero the zero is any
value of x that makes the output or the
Y value zero so graphically what this
means is that say your graph looks like
this these x-intercepts right here are
called zeros or roots or solutions or
x-intercepts but the reason they're
called zeros is because the y-coordinate
is zero you're not going up or down
you're just going you know left or right
along the x-axis so that's why they call
them zeros it's because it's the value
of x that makes Y or the function equal
to zero and you'll use this as you go on
and you know in math so I just want to
show you here like there's different
ways to solve these for these zeros you
could use the quadratic formula you
could factor there's something called
the rational root theorem that we'll be
getting into in another video but for
here I'll just show you the factoring
method on this problem so you can see we
can factor this as X minus 4 X plus 3 we
set these factors equal to 0 so X minus
4 equals 0 or X plus 3 equals 0 so we
get 4 or negative 3 so those are the
zeros those are the values that make
this function equal to 0 for this one we
can do the same thing we could factor it
and set the factors to 0 so let's do
that X plus 3 times X minus 3 equals 0
so your G of x equals 0 so if we set
these factors to 0 you can see we're
going to get negative 3 or positive 3
again that's where the graph is going to
cross the x-axis ok and then in this
problem here we're going to set this
equal to 0 so we've got x squared plus 4
equals 0 x squared equals negative 4
okay so I'm just solving take the square
root of both sides when you take the
square root of a negative number you get
an imaginary number and we talked about
this in a previous video you can take a
look at that if you're interested but
square root of 4 is 2 square root of
negative
is I when you take the square root you
get two answers plus or minus 2i now
because this is imaginary that means
that this graph is not going to cross
the x-axis and we know what this graph
looks like it's a parabola that's been
shifted up four units it's opening up so
you can see it's not crossing the x-axis
that's why we're getting the imaginary
zeros okay so it doesn't have any
x-intercepts so this has been a short
video on how to find zeros and what
zeros represent I'll see you in the next
video